Let me read this to you and
then we'll get to the Q.
And.
A.
I think this,
this is the kind of thing that I'd like
to shed light on in any possible lecture
series on marks.
So this is called invocation
of one in despair.
So God has snatched from me my all
in the curse and rack of destiny.
All his worlds are gone beyond recall.
Nothing but revenge is
left to me on myself.
Revenge all proudly wreak on that being
that enthroned Lord make my strength a
patchwork of what's week.
Leave my better self without reward,
I shall build my throne.
High overhead,
cold,
tremendous shell at summit
be for it's bulwark,
superstitious dread for it's Marshall,
blackest agony who looks on it with a
healthy I shall turn back struck deathly
Pale and dumb clutched by blind and chill
mortality made his happiness prepare
his too.
And the Almighty's lightning shell
rebound from that massive iron giant.
If he bring my walls and towers down,
he turned it.
He shall raise them up defiant.
Well,
so on that happy note,
that's perhaps perhaps some insight into
the spirit that motivated our friend Mr
Carl Marx.
So
I've really been thinking a lot about
the Marxist critique of Western culture,
especially if fundamental,
um,
Marxist critique is something eight
fundamental Mar Marxist critique is a
criticism of the fact that
in capitalist societies,
uh,
a disproportionate amount of the spoils,
let's say the wealth goes
to a disproportionately
small part of the community.
And this is of course a truism by the way,
it is the case that that occurs,
which is why the richest dozen people
in the world have as much money as the
bottom 2 billion,
something like that.
Um,
it's also the case,
it's part of a more generalized law,
sometimes called price's
law and represented with
the peritoneal distribution.
Perico is p a r e t o showing that
not only do the bulk of the spoils,
let's say the wealth go to a
disproportionately small number of people,
but the bulk of the productive work is
also done by a disproportionately small
number of people,
not necessarily the same
people that have the wealth.
By the way,
although in a functional society,
there's some overlap.
Now Mark's was correct and observing that
that happened in capitalist societies,
but incorrect in assuming that there
are any societies that have ever been
formulated or that could
ever be formulated that would
escape from that destiny.
Because you see that same
tremendous Pareto distribution,
that proclivity of wealth to,
to accrue in the hands of small
of a small number of people.
You see that in every human
society that's ever been studied.
And if it's not wealth,
it's sexual access or reproductive,
well that's the same thing.
Reproductive Opportunity,
let's say,
or,
or material possessions,
which is obviously a form of wealth,
et cetera.
So one of the things that
characterizes the west is that all our,
although our society's
produced inequality,
like every other society,
including animal societies,
by the way,
and even among plants,
even among stars,
a disproportionate number of the
heavenly bodies have most of the mass,
by the way,
which is not something that you can
lay at the feet of western capitalism.
Um,
the thing that the West
has been able to do
that other societies haven't been able
to do is to produce wealth along with
inequality.
And that wealth is definitely
a fair proportion of that
wealth is actually going to
benefit the people who are
in the diarists straights.
And that process has been
accelerating over the last 20 years.
So from the year 2000 till the year 2012,
the level of absolute poverty
in the world has halved,
which is the fastest rate of economic
development in the history of the world.
And I think that rate is accelerating,
at least in part because the Soviet Union,
for example,
isn't around anymore to agitate the
economic masters in leaders of developing
countries into the adoption of
counterproductive collectivist economic
strategies.
And so what appears to be happening is
that as we spread the fundamental western
ethos of individuality and private
property and free markets and freedom in
general for men and for
women around the world,
that the poorest people are becoming,
well at least they're not starving.
They're becoming richer even though at
the same time we do pay a price for that
in inequality.
So there's a rule and I don't know how
to formulate it exactly are there seems
to be a rule which is a given unit of
wealth is produced at the cost of of
certain production of inequality,
a certain number of units of inequality
and that seems to be inalienable to some
degree.
So anyways,
that's part of a Marxist
critique the poem first,
which is like you want to listen to
that poem a couple of times I would say,
but then more fundamentally a critique
of the Marxist critique of the West.
Yes,
the West produces inequality,
but it's not something that you
could lay at the feet of capitalism.
It's a much,
much deeper problem.
And what that means too is that those
people who purport to be on the side of
the poor and dispossessed are not being
friends to them by any stretch of the
imagination at all by attempting to tear
down the very hierarchies that seemed
to be leveraging the world's poorest
people out of poverty as rapidly as
possible.
There's evidence as well that people
start to become very concerned about the
environment.
If you can get their family income,
I think are its GDP,
I think up about 40 f above
about 4,500 us a year.
They start to have a little bit of
spare time to be concerned with the
environment around them.
And so the right way to,
to ecological balance in
the world seems to be,
um,
to make people rich as fast as we possibly
can to make the poor rich as fast as
we possibly can.
And wouldn't that be lovely if
that was really the way out.